so he's a pretty ordinary one a little
triangle right now if we want to find
its area at the moment and you seven or
eight or you know in student or you guys
only have one way to find the area of
triangle we have one and one only
formula for the area of charge
what is it I'll give you a good insight
it starts in the heart i think michael c
RZ uh you're you're coming
move your step forward actually right
I'm thinking normally half base times
height right or B and H as an
abbreviation okay now that's the way
that you would normally do this you'll
need some information here right for
instance you might call BC your base in
which case with the height go where
would it go we actually have a word for
this right it's going to be the
perpendicular here we call the altitude
right so I'm actually going to draw that
in it's gotta be perpendicular in order
for that to be the height I'll call that
H and I'll call this point that I've
just made down here pay for point okay
now just before I move on we didn't have
to make BC the base I know it's at the
bottom right but AC could be the base as
well
or a B could be the base you can make
any of them the base you just turn the
thing around and you'll have a different
perpendicular height but just so we're
on the same page we'll keep with this
one now if I know ABC and I know H I can
get the area but just like we had before
with the same row in the cosine rule
trigonometry allows us to work with this
thing even when we don't actually know
if this is let me show you how right in
this little triangle here on the left
what's it called it's cold
I'm sorry I'm going to pause for a
second I want this actually to equal
something else I'm gonna call this C and
call this babe sorry for rename okay so
you called ABB before which is correct
I'm reading a see now that trailer video
left is right angle okay so I can use
all of my you know ancient right angle
triangle trigonis a in this triangle
here if this corner is called capital B
I would normally name this length
lowercase B small B good so I could say
phrases with sign I could say sine of
this angle over here in the left hand
corner should be opposite on my punish
you agree with that obvious it says just
H over B right and the reason why that's
useful is because now I can make H the
subject it should be B sine C and just
like with simultaneous equations if you
can make something to subject you can
get rid of it from any equation where
you need it right instead of saying hi I
can say B sine C right I can I can
substitute it out so let's just do it
right I can say therefore the area of my
big triangle which is a b c that's 1/2
base times height but i'm going to say
what the base is i want the high part in
this particular triangle half
I'm calling the basis bottom leg right I
can call it BC or CV but being that it's
opposite capital a I'm just going to try
to be more concise and just call that
little Hey okay there's my base and I
just worked out what the height was
right it's big sciency C and that's it
that's not too complicated is it
and the beauty of this guy is now you
remember we said oh we would need to
know the base and we need to the height
I don't need to note the height anymore
right I can just get rid of this out of
my diagram now I can go back to my
original triangle no construction is
required I just need to know two sides
and an angle in a similar way that I
need to know like two sides of a hole to
solve some of these right and that's it
area of any triangle okay let's quickly
do an example
okay you can see just like with a cycle
of cosine rule you'll look at the full
particular piece of information okay
because you've got sign here and easy
way to recognize it is you have two
sides at an angle which is usually what
you're expecting for the side okay so I
can use these piece of information to
work out instead of another angle I can
work out the area of the okay so let's
quickly get this together I'm going to
start by saying area equals off a be
science it always has a nice ring to it
it's very easy to remember so here my a
and B I favor two lengths that I'm
having my planning now it's really
important that you reckon that's right C
C's not just any angle in the Triangle
okay it has to be the one in between a
and B it's got to be that one in between
71 degrees just like you can see in the
Triangle we started everything up he is
a he is B and sine C has to be the one
in the middle or if you remember for the
included angle okay if it were this side
that'd be like the straightest angle
that it be sign a or gonna be this angle
to side B you're gonna get something
different right so must be half a be
sizing and for me I'm just you know okay
calculated for this part let's do it to
one decimal place that'll do say again
you could do you
d to point up to two point two three
nine nine three three nine nine ecology
that's one decimal place and it's an
area so one of my units centimeters
we're done skis really really simple
okay
in some ways area is kind of like ah
this is about that hot of a thing to
calculate it is in some ways easier than
sewing on the cosine rule but as I'm
about to show you it's really one piece
with all of the five point three
treatment you've already done